betroffene millionen aufrufe alles klar
ich habe vor einigen tagen acht bekommen
indem ich eine zuschauerin darum gebeten
hat zumal auch sma zu reagieren da habe
ich mir gedacht okay ich jetzt sage ich
nichts besonderes man nicht bekommen
aber zumal nachrichten so aller
reagieren auch blumenkohl oder reagiere
auf die einschulung zu meinem kleinen
bruder aber dann habe ich ein bisschen
gegoogelt und was ich da beim googeln
und auf youtube suchen gesehen habe das
ist mir so den kick gegeben zu sagen
okay darüber machen wie du reagierst
drauf das wird richtig witzig und
deswegen reagieren wir heute auf erste
mal bei meiner recherche darauf gestoßen
dass lukas ein ähnliches video schon
gemacht hat vor einem jahr glaube ich
habe ich den beschreibungen verlinkt
falls ihr mehr dazu sehen wollt aber
fragen wir jetzt mal an ganz vorne was
heißt eigentlich sma ist die abkürzung
für irgendwas scheinbar erst einmal
steht für thomas sensory meridian
response erst einmal aber zeigten die
erfahrung eines staates ähnlichen oder
kribbeln gefühl auf der haut das
typischerweise auf der kopfhaut beginnt
und sich am nacken und der oberen
wirbelsäule entlang bewegt wusste ich
bis jetzt auch noch nicht also erst
einmal aber zeichnen quasi nicht diese
art und weise so zuflüstert in videos
sondern das kribbeln was man dabei
bekommen sollte nachdem wir das
festgestellt haben heute begeben uns auf
youtube und schauen uns mal ein paar
clips an weil da scheppert ein wirklich
aus dem leben was da teilweise gibt ganz
kurz vor der berg habe ich persönlich
nichts gegen sma und das video als auch
nichts gegen leute die erste mal selbst
mögen ich bin eine person die noch nie
ein video gesehen hat jetzt sich die
ersten anschaut und so als
außenstehender drauf guckt und ihre
meinung dazu abgibt dann leute extrem
auf sounds for community also ich
übersetze mal sma uhr lecken extrem und
geräusche für
krimmel immunität was geil alter noch
bevor wir einfach leute schaut euch
dieses vom land was ist das ist das ein
mikrofon was am ende auch formen hat oh
mein gott diese inschrift ich weiß ich
fühle mich unwohl wenn ich das höre gold
leute dieses wie beschäftigt wir sehen
am rand schon mal und es war wie drüben
im tab auf sma ihr cleaning not talking
war
ich hoffe ja kopfhörer dabei erneute
falls nicht wohlig kopf für
wahrscheinlich dass an den kopfhörer das
klingt wirklich als würde auf euren
ohren herum getrommelt werden und eine
sache sagen allgemein sind das für mich
immer hübsche mädels die dieser sma
videos machen und die machen damit
ziemlich viele aufrufe 2,3 millionen zum
beispiel bevor sogar noch versagen die
richtung das war keine sexuelle erregung
von mir gerade das ist einfach so
seltsam es ist so seltsam und ein krieg
ich das gefühl als wäre jemand direkt in
eurem ohr
oh oh ich hoffe leute ich sehe jetzt
sich alle hardcore fans und hättet mich
gerade weil ich finde das wirklich
heftig ist fühlt sich für mich an als
wäre jemand direkt hinter mir
also ist jetzt keine es fühlt sich an
als wäre jemand direkt hinter mir und
ich finde das mega unangenehm das
erinnert mich irgendwann auch auf filme
ok es so langsam
ich muss sagen so langsam kommt weil wir
an so langsam finde ich gar nicht mehr
nur creepy die 45 sekunden in dem video
drin ist auf einmal nicht mehr so
seltsam aber was mich noch sex empfinde
jetzt gerade ist dass sie gerade gesagt
hat dass das hier in ihr liebling video
ist also eine uhr lag video
ich will sagen es gibt mal vor
es ist nicht übertrieben gerade leute
das ist so seltsam nicht nur die
geräusche an sich sind seltsam sondern
was auch seltsam ist ist das youtube
2018 das ein großes ding ist ich
verurteile das nicht aber lasst uns
darüber nachdenken was da gerade
passiert die sitzt an irgendeiner
konstruktionen was scheinbar ein
mikrofon ist und das mikrofon hat an
beiden enden ohren
okay ein bisschen wird aber okay was sie
aber jetzt macht sich nicht im video
und das ist der haut aufhänger von
diesem video ist diese uhren abzulenken
und dabei so schwarz geräusche zu machen
ich weiß nicht ich für mich kein
bisschen alt
jetzt finde ich ok aber mir ist jetzt
anders springt hin und her zwischen mega
seltsam und irgendwie eigentlich ganz
okay ich sag jetzt mal durch die blume
leute diese geräusche erinnern mich
eventuell an die ein oder andere art und
weise vielleicht den geschlechtsverkehr
zu praktizieren ohne die primären
geschlechtsmerkmale einzusetzen was
jetzt wiederum nicht ganz schlecht ist
aber wo es gab was ich glaube gehören
wie sagt man nicht leute nach dem was
ich gesagt habe denkt euch mal was habe
ich mir gerade gedacht was wohl relativ
viele leute bei diesem video machen
werde sich dieses video anschauen
ich sage es mal dazu mache weiter mit
erste tierklinik motor ging das kommt
von einem japanischen erster kanal und
das kann nur gut sein ich habe echt
schon über die scheiße von japanern
gesehen okay ich hab mal das sind so
oder ähnliche dinge das sind wir
ich weiß nicht ich bin einfach das ist
wirklich selbst war dass es mich mit
erst einmal auseinander setzte ich bin
ein bisschen geschockt ich kann doch ein
bisschen nachvollziehen ehrlich gesagt
weil es fühlt sich wirklich so an als
wenn man kopfhörer auf hat deswegen hat
sich die kopfhörer leute als ob leute
wenn in meinem ohr um schaffen würden
mit irgendwelchen steffen ich bin nicht
ganz sicher ob das jetzt gut oder
schlecht ist
jetzt geht er daran dass für mich
richtig psychoterror leute ich springe
die ganze zeit so emotional und
gedanklich zwischen okay ist ganz
angenehm und es ist einfach so seltsam
und schlimm und gerade das ja sowieso
immer was am trommelfell sein soll darum
spielen auf gar keinen fall hier haben
wir es immer wieder
das ist krieg die leute ja ich schaute
zu als youtuber drauf wenn ich so etwas
sehe denke ich viel darüber nach wird
die das gerade aufgenommen weil das ist
auch mein job nicht an der kamera auf
überlegen ja welcher winkel wie verhalte
ich mich vor der kamera ihr müsst ihr
mal vorstellen versetze ich mal in sie
rein jetzt hier gerade versucht durch
ihre augen zu schauen sie liegt in ihrem
bett das irgendwo lampen von der seite
und vor ihr steht einfach nur eine
kamera auf dem stativ und die redet
gerade mit der kamera und streiche die
kamera als wäre gerade ihr geliebter
oder freund reingekommen aber ich stelle
euch mal vor da ist auch noch die kamera
die macht das cover der kamera wie
selbst ist das denn
also wie gesagt leute ich weiß gar nicht
beurteilen ich kann das nachvollziehen
dass man sich das zum einschlafen hat
zumindest die anderen sachen bei der
hier könnte ich mir eher vorstellen dass
wenn man sich irgendwie verraten soll
einsam fühlt oder sowas auch vorkommt
und man jetzt gerade hat er mit einem
bett legen will
ich kenne das gefühl glaubt mir spaß
dann gerade wahrscheinlich zu sowas wenn
man irgendwie so alleine ist nie das
gefühl haben wir jemand ist bei einem
aber ein bisschen ist es schon oder
nicht nur ein bisschen halt ein bisschen
deutsch des german explodiert
bitte nicht russischen akzent dass ich
finde dass also wollte ich weiß nicht
also ich meine absicht digitalkamera und
ging zum mikrofon hin erst mal wie gern
weil das ist so eine art video und alle
liegen sie darin schildern sich sehen
wann zuständigen sich sogar einen panels
oder andere sachen machen und wollen
nicht drauf eingehen und dann geht es
ans mikro ganz leise und das war
wahrscheinlich ziemlich lustig boppard
hier ist noch etwas hier ein geschickt
habt kickl sma meetings sounds also
erstmal saarbrücken essen
drogba 1 million darauf berufe alles
klar
ich bin raus man fast 13 millionen
aufrufe
das war es komplett für mich leute ich
bin absolut raus aus meinem leben jetzt
ich hab euch rüber zu einer folge von
was geht von meinem format mit
unitymedia und würde mich freuen wenn
der kanal ab checkt und gerne mal voraus
ich würde sagen es fährt jeder der den
kanal abonniert bekommt brasilien hier
den kanal abonniert bekommt einmal
brasilien hat das ganze land mit allen
rohstoffen menschen und industrieller
allem darin einfach jeder des leicht
bekommt sein eigenes posiert alles klar